okay hi everyone so let's get started
today so today's lecture what I'm going
to do is be talking about question
answering over text this is another of
the big successes in using deep learning
inside natural language processing and
it's also a technology that has some
really obvious commercial uses so it's
some it's an area that's attracted a lot
of attention in the last couple of years
so this is the overall plan just a
couple of reminders and things at the
beginning about final project stuff and
then for basically all of it is talking
about question answering starting with
motivation history talking about the
squad data a particular simple model our
stand for the 10th of reader then
talking about some other more complex
stuff into the most modern stuff yeah so
in a sense this lecture serves a double
purpose because if you're going to do
that the default final project well it's
about textual question answering and
this is your chance to learn something
about the area of textual question
answering and the kinds of models you
might want to be thinking about and
building but the content of this lecture
pretty much is in no way specifically
tied to the default final project apart
from by subject matter then really it's
telling you about how people use neural
nets to build question answering systems
okay so it's first us quickly on the
reminders mid-quarter survey I mean a
huge number of people have actually
filled this in already we're already at
over 60% I'm filling it in rate both
which by the standards of people who do
surveys they can as a huge success
already but if you're not in that
percent we'd still love to have your
feedback and now's the perfect time to
do it yeah I just wanted to sort of have
a note on custom final projects so in
general it's great to get feedback on
custom final projects there's a formal
mechanism for that which is the project
proposal that I mentioned last time it's
also great to chat to people informally
about
final projects and so I'm one of those
people and I've have been talking to
lots of people about final projects and
are very happy to do so but there's sort
of a problem that there's only one of me
so I do also encourage you to realize
that among the various TAS that really
lots of them have had experience of
different deep learning projects and in
particular on the office hours page
there's a table that like this but you
can read it if you look at it on your
own laptop which talks about the
experience of different TAS and many of
them have experience in different areas
and many of them were also good people
to talk to about final projects okay so
for the default final project the
textual question answering
so draft materials for that are out
today right now on the website actually
we're calling them draft because we
think that they're still probably a few
things that are going to get changed
over the next week so don't regard as
completely final in terms of the code
but you know it's sort of 90% fine also
in terms of deciding whether you're
going to do a custom final project or a
default final project and working out
what you're putting into your project
proposal it should be you know well more
than what you need for this year okay
then one other final bit I just wanted
to say that I didn't get to last time is
so for the final projects regardless of
which kind you're doing well part of it
is doing some experiments of doing stuff
with data and code and getting some
numbers and things like that but I do
really encourage people to also remember
that an important part of the final
project is writing a final project
report and this is no different to any
research project of the kinds that
students do for conferences or journals
and things like that right you spend
months commonly working over your code
and experiments but in most cases the
main evaluation of your work is from
people reading a written paper
output version of things so it's really
important that that paper version sort
of reflects the work that you did and
the interesting ideas that you came up
with and explains them well and present
your experiments and all of those things
and so encourage you to sort of do a
good job at writing up your projects
he is just sort of a vague outline of
you know what a typical project write-up
is likely to look at like now there
isn't really one size completely fits
all because depending on what you've
done different things might be
appropriate but you know typically the
first page will have an abstract for the
paper and the introduction to the paper
you'll spend some time talk about
related prior work you'll talk about
what kind of models you built for a
while there's probably some discussion
of what data you're using for your
projects experiment commonly with some
tables and figures about things that
you're doing more tables and figures
talking about the results as to how well
your systems were it's great to have
some error analysis to see what kind of
things that you got right and wrong and
then maybe at the end there's sort of
plans for the future conclusions or
something like that okay that's sort of
it for my extra administrative reminders
are there any questions on final
projects that people are dying to know
okay or good luck I spent to say good
luck yeah good luck your final projects
okay so now moving into yeah the
question answering okay so I mean so
question answering is a very direct
application for something that human
beings want to do or maybe human beings
don't in general want to know this
here's my query of who was Australia's
third prime minister
maybe yeah that's not really the kind of
thing you're gonna put into your queries
but you know maybe your query who is the
lead singer a big thief or something
like that I don't know
yeah but you know lots a large
percentage of stuff on the web is that
people actually are asking for answers
to questions and so if I put in this
query into Google it actually just works
it tells me the answer is John Christian
Watson and so that's sort of
question-answering working in the real
world now if you try different kinds of
questions in Google you'll find that
some of them work and Lots them don't
work and when they don't work you're
just sort of getting whatever kind of
information retrieval web search results
there is one fine point that I just
wanted to mention down here so another
thing that Google has is the Google
knowledge graph which is a structured
graph representation of knowledge and
some kinds of questions are being
answered from that structured knowledge
representation and so I mean quite a lot
of the time for things like movies it's
coming from that structured graph if
you're so saying who's the director of a
movie or something like that but this
answer isn't coming from that this
answer is the genuine the kind of stuff
we're going to talk about today its
textual question answering from a
webpage where Google's question
answering system has extracted the
answer and sticking it up there if
you're wanting to explore these things
if you get one of these boxes sort of
down here where I cut it off there's a
little bit of gray that says how did I
get this result and if you click on that
it actually will tells you what's all
getting it from and you can see if it's
doing it from the textual question
answering system or from something like
the knowledge graph okay
so in general the motivation for
question answering is that these days
there's just these sort of massive
collections of full-text documents ie
there's the web so that there are sort
of billions of documents of information
and traditionally when people first
started thinking about search
information retrieval as a field you
know nothing of that kind of quantity
and size existed right that when people
first started building search systems it
was sort of unthinkable to index whole
documents because no one had hard disk
big enough in those days right then
really they were indexing titles or
titles and abstracts or something like
that and so it seemed perfectly adequate
in those days to say okay we're just
going to send you you give you your
results as to here's a list of documents
because the documents are only 100 words
long but that's clearly not the case now
when we have these sort of you know 10
minute read medium posts and which might
have the answer to a question and so
there's this need to sort of say well
can we just have systems that will give
us answers to questions and a lot of the
recent changes in technology have hugely
underlined that need so since returning
documents works ok if you're sitting at
your laptop but it works really terribly
if you're on your phone and it works
even more terribly if you're trying to
work with speech on a digital assistant
device something like an Alexa system
and so we really want to actually be
able to produce systems that can give
the answers to people's questions and so
typically doing that is factored into
two parts that the first part of that is
we still do information retrieval we use
stat
normally quite standard information
retrieval techniques to find documents
that quite likely to complain to contain
an answer and the reason this is
normally done by quite traditional tech
Meek's is because the traditional
techniques are extremely scalable over
billions of documents
whereas current Newell systems actually
aren't really scalable over billions of
documents though that's an area and sort
of which researchers ongoing but then
once we have sort of some candidate
likely documents we want to find do they
contain an answer and if so what is the
answer and so at that point we have a
document or a paragraph and we're saying
can we answer this question from there
and then that problem is often referred
to as the reading comprehension problem
and so that's really what I'm going to
focus on today reading comprehension
isn't a new problem
I mean it's you can trace it back into
the early days of artificial
intelligence and NLP so back in the 70s
a lot of NLP work was trying to do
reading comprehension I mean one of the
famous strands of that was so Roger
shank was a famous early in LP person
not a terribly nice man I don't think
actually but the Yale School of AI was a
very well known NOP approach and really
it was very focused on reading
comprehension but it's sort of you know
I think I was sort of the time was too
early in any way it sort of died out
nothing much came out of that but then
in right just before the turn of them
and millennium Lynette Hirshman revived
this idea and said well maybe a good
challenge would be to find the kind of
reading comprehension questions that
elementary school kids do and let's see
if we could get computers to do that and
some people tried that with fairly
simple methods which only work mediocre
ly then sort of somewhat after that
Chris Burgess who was a guy who was at
Microsoft Research and he wasn't really
an NLP person at all you as a machine
learning person but he got it into his
head that well really a big problem that
should be being worked on his machine
comprehension and he suggested that you
sort of could codify it like this
and this is a particular clean
codification that has lived on and we'll
look at more today right so a machine
comprehends a passage of text if there
any question regarding that text that
can be answered correctly by majority of
native speakers that machine can provide
a string which those speakers would
agree both answers that question and
does not contain information irrelevant
to that question and he sort of proposed
this as sort of a challenge problem for
artificial intelligence and said about
collecting a corpus the MCTS corpus
which was meant to be a simple reading
comprehension challenge so they
collected stories which were meant to be
kids stories you know Alyssa got to the
beach after a long trip she's from
Charlotte she traveled from Atlanta
she's now in Miami sort of pretty easy
stuff and then there are questions why
did Alyssa go to Miami and then the
answer is to visit some friends and so
you've got there this string that is
coming from the passage that's the
answer to the question so the MC test is
a corpus of about 600 such stories and
that challenge existin a few people
worked on it but that never really went
very far either for the next couple of
years but what really changed things was
that in 2015 and then with more stuff in
deep learning people got interest in
this idea of could we perhaps build
neural question-answering systems and it
seemed like if you wanted to do that
something like MC test could only be a
test set and the way to make progress
would be to do what have been done in
other domains and to actually build just
hand build a large training set of
passages questions and answers in such a
way that would be able to train your
networks using the kind of supervised
learning techniques that we've
concentrated on so far in this class and
indeed the kind of supervised neural
network learning techniques which is
actually the successful
stuff that powers nearly all the
applications of deep learning not only
an NLP and also in other fields like
vision and so the first such sis the
first such data set was built by people
at deep mind over CNN Daily Mail news
stories but then the next year
um Pavarotti / KU is a Stanford PhD
student working with Percy Liang and a
couple of other students and produced
the squad data set which was actually a
much better designed data said and
proved to be sort of much more
successful at driving this forward and
then following along from that other
people started to produce lots of other
question-answering datasets which you
know many of them have interesting
advantages and disadvantages of their
own including ms marco trivia QA race
lots of them but for today's class I'm
going to concentrate on squad because
squad is actually the one that has been
by far the most widely used and because
it it was just a well-constructed clean
data set that sort of just proved a
profitable one for people to work with
okay
um so that was reading comprehension I
also just quickly tell you the the
history of open domain question
answering so the difference here for the
field of open domain question answering
that we're saying okay there's an
encyclopedia or there's a web crawl I'm
just going to ask a question can you
answer it so it's this bigger task of
question answering and you know that was
something that again was thought about
very early on so this kind of early
kakum paper by Simmons who sort of
explores how you could do answering
questions as textual question answering
and yet here he has the idea that what's
going to happen is you're going to
dependency parse the question and
dependency parse sentences of the text
and then sort of do tree matching over
the dependency parsers to get out the
answers and you know that's in some
it's actually prefigured work that
people actually were then attempting to
do 35 years later getting a bit more
modern Julian Cope yet she was working
at Xerox PARC at the time came up with
this system called murex and so at this
stage in the 90s that started to be the
first digitally available encyclopedias
available so he was using the Gro Leah's
encyclopedia and so he said about trying
to build a system that could answer
questions over that encyclopedia using
in general fairly sort of shallow
linguistic processing methods ie regular
expressions after having done with
information retrieval search over that
but that started to evoke more interest
from other people and so in 1999 the US
National Institutes of Standards and
Technology instituted a trick question
answering track where the idea was
there's a large collection of newswire
documents and you could be asked to
provide the question of them and lots of
people start to build question answering
systems indeed even in some sense it was
this competition which was where people
at IBM started working on textual
question answering and then sort of a
decade later IBM rejigged things into
the sexier format of let's build a
jeopardy contestant rather than let's
answer questions from the news and that
then led to their deep QA system in 2011
which I presume quite a few of you saw
these people saw jeopardy
IBM yeah some of you okay so that they
were able to successfully build a
question answering system that could
compete at jeopardy and win and you know
like a lot of these demonstrations of
technological success there are things
you can quibble about the way it was set
up that really they're kind of computer
just had a speed advantage
the human beings that had to buzz in to
answer the question but you know
nevertheless fundamentally the textual
question answering had to work that this
was a system that was answering
questions mainly based on textual
passages and it had to be able to find
the answers to those questions correctly
and for the system to work so then more
recently again and really the first
piece of work that did this with a
neural system was work those done by a
Stanford PhD student that I'll get to
later was then the idea of well could we
replace traditional complex question
answering systems by using a neural
reading comprehension system and that's
proved to be very successful so to
explain that a little bit more if you
look at the kind of systems that were
built for Trek question answering
they were very complex multi-part
systems and really if you then look at
something like ibm's deep QA system it
was sort of like this times 10 because
it both had very complex systems like
this but an ensemble together sort of
six different components in every place
and then did sort of classify a
combination on top of them but so forth
the kind this is sort of a round a sort
of a 2003 question answering system and
so the kind of things that went through
is so when there is a question it passed
the question with a parser kind of like
the ones we saw our dependency parsers
it did some sort of handwritten semantic
normalization rules to try and get that
into a better semantic form it then had
a question type classifier which tried
to work out what kind of semantic type
is this question looking for is it
looking for a person name or a country
name or a temperature or something like
that it would then have an information
retrieval system out of the document
collection which would find paragraphs
that were likely to contain the answers
and then it would have a method of
ranking those paragraph choices
see which ones are likely to have the
answers
it would then over there somewhere
run named entity recognition on those
passages to find entities that were in
them these systems depends strongly on
the use of fine matching entities
because then it could look for an entity
which corresponding to the question type
then once it had candidate entities it
would actually try and determine whether
these entities did or didn't answer the
question so these people this is a
system from LCC by Sutton to her about
you and Dan or Devon they actually had
some quite interesting stuff here where
they had a kind of a loose theorem
prover that would try and prove that the
semantics form of a piece of text
gave an answer to what the question was
so you know that was kind of cool stuff
with an ex emetic knowledgebase and
eventually out would come and answer so
you know something that is I do just
want to emphasize you know sometimes
with these deep learning courses you get
these days the impression you have is
that absolutely nothing worked before
2014 where we got back to deep learning
and that's not actually true so these
kind of factoids question are these kind
of question answering systems within a
certain domain actually really worked
rather well so I started saying the word
factoid question answering and so let me
explain that because that's the secret
so people at least in NLP use the term
factoid question answering to mean the
case that your answer is a named entity
so it's sort of something like you know
what year was overs Presley born or what
is the name of Beyonce's husband or you
know which state has the most pork or
something I don't know write anything
that's got anything that saw the answer
is sort of some clear semantic type
entity and that's your answer I mean so
within the space of those kind of
questions which actually is a
significant part of the questions you
get web search right lots of
web search is just you know who was the
star of this movie or what year was
somebody born right there's zillions of
those all the time these systems
actually really did work quite well that
they could get about 70% of those
questions right which wasn't bad at all
though that they really sort of didn't
really extend out to other kinds of
stuff beyond that but whatever virtues
they had they were extremely complex
systems that people spent years put
together putting together which had many
components with a huge amount of
hand-built stuff and most of the stuff
was sort of built quite separately and
tied together and you just sort of hoped
that it worked well when put together in
composite and so we can contrast that to
what we then see later for neural
network style systems okay so let me now
say some more stuff about the Stanford
questioning answering data set or squad
that I just mentioned a little bit ago
and this is the data for the default
final project as well
so what Squad has is questions in squad
have a passage which is a paragraph from
Wikipedia and then there is a question
here it's which team won Super Bowl 50
and the goal of the system is to come up
with the answer to this question human
reading comprehension what is the answer
the question
Broncos Wonka yeah and so that's the
answer to the question and so by
construction for squad the answer to a
question is always a subsequence of
words from the passage which is normally
ends up being referred to as a span a
subsequence of words from the passage so
that's the only kind of questions you
can have you can't have questions that
are counting questions or yes/no
questions or anything like that you can
just pick out a subsequence okay but so
they created in the first version about
a hundred thousand examples so there are
a bunch of questions about each passage
so it's sort of something like I think
it's maybe sort of about five questions
per passage and there are 20,000
different bits of Wikipedia use it used
and this sort of must be a span form is
often referred to as extractive question
answering okay
here's just one more example that can
give you some more sense of some of the
things that are there and it illustrates
a couple of other factors so you know
even this one I guess the previous one
wasn't completely obvious what your
answer should be because maybe you could
say the answer should just have been
Broncos or you could have said it was
Denver Broncos and in general even if
you're answering with a span there's
going to be variation as to how long a
span you choose so what they did and so
this was done with on Mechanical Turk
gathering the data of building questions
and getting answers is that they got
answers from three different people so
here's this question along with non
governmental and non state schools what
is another name for private schools and
three human beings were asked the answer
based on this passage and one said
independent and who said independent
schools this one all three people gave
the same answer this one again you get
two different answers so that they
sample three answers and basically then
you can beaker
recked if you're going with any of the
answers and so that sort of at least
gives you a bit of robustness to
variation in human answers okay and that
starts me into the topic of evaluation
yeah and these slides here I'm titled
squad version 1.1 because that means in
five minutes time I'm going to tell you
about squad version two which adds a bit
more stuff into it but we'll just get
one point one straight first okay so
there are three answers that were
collected and so for evaluation metrics
they suggested to evaluation metrics the
first one is exact match so you're going
to return a span if the span is one of
these three you get one point and if the
scan it in span is not one of these
three you get zero for that question and
then your accuracy is just the percent
correct so that's extremely simple but
the second metric and actually the one
that was favored as the primary metric
was an F 1 metric so what do you do for
this F 1 metric is your matching at the
word level for the different answers so
you treat each you treat the system span
and each gold answer as a bag of words
and then you work out a precision which
is the percent of words in the systems
answer that are actually in a span in a
gold spare and the recall which is the
percent of words in the gold span that
are in the systems span and then you
calculate the harmonic mean of those two
numbers and the harmonic means sort of a
very conservative average so it's close
to the min of those two numbers and that
gives you a score and what you then do
is for each question you'd but you say
it's score is the maximum if one over
the three different answers that are
collected from human beings and then for
the whole data set you then average
those f1 scores across questions and
that's then your final
one result so that's a more complicated
thing to say and we provide they're sort
of a vowel code for you that does that
but it's sort of seems that f1 is
actually a more reliable and better
measure because if you use exact match
you know even though there's a bit of
robustness that comes from three
people's answers threes not a very large
sample so there's sort of a bit of
guessing as to whether you get exactly
the same span some human being got
whereas you're sort of going to get a
reasonable score in the f1 even if your
boundaries are off by a little so the f1
metric sort of is more reliable and
avoids various kinds of artifacts as to
how big or small and answer human beings
tend to choose in some circumstances and
so that sort of being used as the
primary metric that people score people
on in the leaderboards final detail both
metrics um ignore punctuation and the
English articles are and that okay so
how did things work out so first squad
version 1.1 a long time ago at the end
of 2016 this is how the leaderboard
looked and this is the bottom of the
leaderboard at this point in time
because that allows me to show you a
couple of things so down the bottom of
the leaderboard so they tested how well
human beings did at answering these
questions because you know human beings
aren't perfect and answering questions
either and so the human performance
would they measured had an f1 score of
91 point two and here I'll come back to
that again in a minute and so when they
built the data set they built a logistic
regression baseline which was sort of a
conventional NLP system so they
dependency parsed the question and
sentences of the answer they looked for
dependency so dependency link matches so
a word at both ends with a
see relation in between and countin
matches of those as sort of pointing to
a likely answer so it's sort of a fairly
competently build traditional NOP system
of this not as complex Aires but it's
sort of in the same vein of that earlier
question answering system I mentioned
and it got an f1 of about fifty one so
not hopeless but not that great compared
to human beings and so very shortly
after that people then started building
neural network systems to try and do
better at this task on this data set and
so one of the first people to do this
quite successfully were these people
from Singapore Management University
maybe not the first place you would've
thought of but they were really so the
first people who showed that yes you
could build and in to entrain neural
network for this task and Duke rather
better and so they got up to 67 f1 and
well then they had a second system we
got up to 70 and then things started to
go on so that even by the end of 2016
there started to be systems that really
worked rather well on this task so here
at this time was the top of the
leaderboard so I'll talk later about
this by deaf system from the F AI to
Allen Institute for artificial
intelligence and the University of
Washington so I was going to 77 as a
single system but like in just about all
machine learning people pretty soon
noticed that if you made an ensemble of
identically structured systems you could
push the number higher and so if you
want sümbül those you could then get
another sort of whatever it is about
four points and get up to 81 f1 and so
this was sort of around the situation
when in the tower 2017 to 24 in class we
first use squad version 1 as a as a
default final project and
that point you know actually the best
students got almost to the top of this
leaderboard so our best CS 224 in final
project in winter 2017 made it into the
equivalent of fourth place on this
leaderboard with seventy seven and a
half as their score so that was really
rather cool but that's a couple of years
ago and since then people have started
building bigger and bigger and more and
more complex systems and so essentially
you could sort of say that squad version
one is basically solved so the very best
systems and now getting f1 scores that
are in the low 90s and in particular you
can see that the best couple of systems
have higher F ones and well higher exact
matches than what was measured for human
beings now like a lot of the claims of
deep learning being better and
performing from human being than human
beings they're sort of semester ist's
you can put after that I mean in
particular for this data said the way
they measured human performance was a
little bit unfair because they only
actually collected three human beings
answers so to judge the human
performance the hue those each of those
humans was being scored versus only two
other humans and so that means you only
had two chances to match instead of
three so there's actually sort of a
systematic underscoring of the human
performance but whatever systems got
very good at doing this so the next step
was then to introduce the squad versat
version to tasks and so many people felt
that a defect of squad version one was
that in all cases questions had answers
so that you just had to find the answer
in the paragraph and so that sort of
turned into a kind of a ranking task you
just had to work out what seems the most
likely answer I'll return that without
really having any idea of whether it was
an answer to the question or not and so
for squad version 2 for the Devin test
sets half of the questions have answers
and half of the questions just don't
have an answer in the passage that's
slightly different distribution the
training data and the way it works for
scoring is the sort of like the no
answer kind of counts as like one word
as a sort of a special token so if the
its if it should be in no answer and you
say no answer you get a score one and
the either exact match or the f measure
and if you don't do that you get a score
of zero and so the simplest way of
approaching squad 2.0 would be to say
well rather than just always returning
the best match in my system I'll use
some kind of threshold and only if the
scores above a threshold
I'll count as an answer you could do
more sophisticated things so another
area that we've worked on quite a bit at
Stanford is this natural language
inference task that I'll talk about
later in the course but that's really
about saying whether one piece of text
is a conclusion of another piece of text
and so that's sort of a way that you can
try and see whether a piece of text
actually gives you a justification and
answer to what the question was but
anyway this just trying to sucide
whether you've actually gone answer or
not is a quite difficult problem in many
cases so here's an example from squad
2.0 so Genghis Khan United the Mongol
and turkic tribes of the steppes and
became Great Khan in 1206 he and his
successors expanded the Mongol Empire
across Asia above Omaha and the question
is when did Genghis Khan kill Great Khan
and the answer to that is you know there
isn't an answer because actually Genghis
Khan was a person named Great Khan and
he didn't kill a great car
it's just not a question with an answer
but it's precisely what happens with
systems is you know even though these
systems get high scores in terms of
points they don't actually understand
human language that well so they look at
something that says when did Genghis
Khan kill Great Khan well this is
something that's looking for a date and
there are some obvious dates in this
passage there's 1206 1234 1251 and well
there's kill and kill looks a little bit
similar to destroyed I can see the word
destroyed so that's probably kind of
matches and then we're talking about
Genghis Khan and there I can see Genghis
and Khan in this passage and so it sort
of puts that together and says 1234 is
the answer when that isn't the answer at
all and that's actually kind of pretty
typical of the behavior of these systems
and so that on the one hand they work
great on the other hand they don't
actually understand that much and
effectively asking whether there's this
question is actually answered in the
passage is a way of revealing the extent
to which these models do or don't
understand what's actually going on okay
so at the time they built squad version
2.0 they took some of the existing squad
version 1 systems and modified them in a
very simple way I put in a threshold
score as to how good the final match was
deemed to be and said well how well do
you do on squad 2.0 and the kind of
systems that we saw doing well before
now didn't do that well so something
like the by def system that we mentioned
before was now scoring about 62 f1 so
that that was sort of hugely lowering
its performance and reflecting the
limits of understanding but it turned
out actually that this problem didn't
prove to be quite as difficult as
the data said authors maybe thought
either because it turns out that here we
are now in February 2000 19 and if you
look at the top of the leaderboard we're
kinda getting close again to the point
where the best systems are almost as
good as human being so the current top
rate system there you can see is getting
eighty seven point six F 1 which is less
than two points behind by the human
beings are the squad version two they
also corrected the scoring of human
beings so it's more of a fair evaluation
this time so there's still a bit of a
gap but you know the systems are
actually doing really well and the
interesting thing there is you know on
the one hand these systems are
impressively good you can go on the
squad website and look at the output of
several of the good systems and you can
see that there are just a ton of things
that they get right there absolutely not
bad systems you have to be a good system
to be getting five out of six of the
questions right but you know on the
other hand they still make quite
Elementary natural language
understanding errors and so here's an
example of one of those okay so this one
the Yuan Dynasty is considered both the
successors of the Mongol Empire and an
imperial Chinese dynasty it was the
carnate ruled by the successors of
monkey accom after the division of the
Mongkol empire in official chinese
histories the Yuan disty bore the
Mandate of Heaven following the Song
Dynasty
and preceding the Ming Dynasty okay and
then the question is what dynasty came
before the yuan and that's a pretty easy
question I'd hoped from a human being
everyone can answer that question okay
yeah so it says in the fish'll Chinese
history so you're under this else I
didn't know the extended s-- yeah follow
it right the you wanders the following
the Song Dynasty and preceding them in
Ming Dynasty but you know actually this
sort of the leading Google Bert Morrill
says that it was the Ming Dynasty that
came before the around in a
the witch you know is sort of Elementary
wrong but you know reveals some of the
same kind of it's not really
understanding everything but it's doing
a sort of a matching problem still okay
so this squad dataset has been useful
and good it still has some major
limitations and I just thought I'd
mention what a few of those are so you
aware of some of the issues so one of
them I've already mentioned right that
you're in this space we're all answers
are a span from the passage and that
just limits the kind of questions you
can ask in the kind of difficult
situations there can be so there can't
be yes/no questions counting questions
or even any of the sort of more
difficult implicit questions so if you
think back to when you're in middle
school and did reading comprehension I
mean it wasn't typically the case that
you were being asked questions that were
just stated explicitly in the text of
you know sue is visiting her mother in
Miami and the question was who is sue
visiting in Miami that wasn't the kind
of questions you were asked you were
normally asked questions like you know
sue is going to a job interview this
morning it's a really important job
interview for her future at breakfast
she starts buttering both sides of her
piece of toast and you're asked a
question like why is sue buttering both
sides of her piece of toast and you're
meant to be able to answer she's
distracted by her important job
interview coming up later in the day
which isn't something that you can
answer by just picking out a sub Spann a
second problem which is sort of actually
a bigger problem is the way Squad was
constructed for ease and not to be too
expensive and various other reasons
was paragraphs of Wikipedia was selected
and then mechanical Turkish were hired
to say come up with some questions that
can be answered by these this passage in
version 1.1 and then in version 2 they
were said told also come up with some
questions that look like they're related
to this passage but aren't actually
answered in the passage but in all cases
people are coming up with the questions
staring at the passage and if you do
that it means that your questions are
strongly overlapping with the passage
both in terms of the the words that are
used and even the syntactic structures
that are used for your questions tending
to match the syntactic structures of the
passage and so that makes question
answering unnaturally easy what happens
in the real world is that human beings
think up questions and type something
into a search engine and the way that
they type it in is completely distinct
from the way something might be worded
on a website so that they might be
saying something like you know in what
year did the price of hard disk drop
below a dollar a megabyte and the
webpage will say something like the cost
of hard disks has been dropping for many
years in I know whenever it was 2004
prices eventually crossed the dollar
megabyte barrier or something like that
there's a quite different discussion of
the ideas and that kind of matching is
much harder and that's one of the things
that people have done other datasets
have tried to do differently another
limitation is that these questions and
answers have very much find the sentence
as addressing the fact match your
questions the sentence return the right
thing that there's nothing sort of more
difficult than involves multi sentence
combined facts together styles of
inferencing that the
limits of cross sentence stuff there is
is pretty much limited to resolving
coreference which is something we'll
talk about later in the class but means
that you see a he or she o in it and you
can work out who that refers to earlier
in the discourse nevertheless despite
all those disadvantages it's sort of
proof that Squad was you know a well
targeted in terms of its level of
differed a well structured clean dataset
and has just been sort of everybody's
favorite for a question arm string data
said it also seems to have proved that
actually for people who work in industry
and want to build a question-answering
system starting off by training a model
and squad actually turns out to work
pretty well it turns out I mean it's not
everything you want to do you definitely
want to have relevant in domain data and
be using that as well but you know it
turns out that it seems to actually be a
quite useful starting point okay so what
I want to show you now was a is a
concrete simple neural question
answering system and this is the model
that was built by
here and I guess she was of an ABI
predecessor since she was the preceeding
head TA for CS 224 n so this system
Stanford attentive reader it kind of
gets cold now I mean this is sort of
essentially the simplest neural
question-answering system that works
pretty well so it's not a bad thing to
have in mind as a baseline it's not the
current state of the art by any means
but you know if you're sort of wondering
what's the simplest thing that I can
build that basically works as a question
answering system decently this is
basically it okay so how does this work
so the way it works is like this so
first of all we have a question which
team won Super Bowl 50 and what we're
going to want to do is build a
representation of a question as a vector
and the way we can do that is like this
for each word and the question we look
up a word embedding so in particular it
use glove glove three hundred
dimensional word embeddings we then run
an LS TM forward through the question
and then kind of like Abby talked about
we actually make it a by Alice TM so we
run a second LST and backwards through
the question and so then we grab the end
state of both LS TM s and we simply
concatenate them together into a vector
of dimension 2d if our hidden states of
the lsdm a dimension D and we say that
is the representation of the question
okay so once we have that we then start
looking at the passage and so for the
start of dealing with the passage we do
the same thing we look up a word vector
for every word and the passage and we
run a bi-directional STM now being
represented a bit more compactly across
the passage but then we have to do a
little bit more work because we actually
have to find the answer in the passage
and so what we're going to do is use the
question representation to sort of work
out where the answer is using attention
so this is a different use of attention
to machine translation the kind of
attention equations are still exactly
the same but we've can now got this sort
of one question vector that we're going
to be trying to match against to return
the answer so what we do is we work out
an attention score between each words by
ostium representation and the question
and so the way that's being done is
we're using this by linear attention
that Abby briefly discussed and we'll
see more of today we've got the question
vector the vector for a particular
position in the passage the two
concatenated lsdm hidden States so
they're the same dimensionality we have
this intervening learn W matrix so we
work out that quantity for each position
and then we put that through a softmax
which will give us probabilities over
the different words in the passage and
those give us our attention weights and
so at that point we have attention
weights for different positions in the
passage and we just declare that that is
where the answer starts and then to get
the end of the answer we simply do
exactly the same thing again apart from
we train a different W matrix here and
we have that predict the end token and
there's something a little bit subtle
here because you know really we're
asking it to sort of predict the starts
and the ends of the answer and you might
think but wait a minute surely we need
to look at the middle of the answer as
well because maybe the the most
indicative words are actually going to
be in the middle of the answer but you
know really really what we we're sort of
implicitly telling the model of
well when you're training if there's
stuff in the middle that's useful
it's the by ostians job to push it to
the extremes of the span so that this
simple by linear attention will be able
to get a big score at the start of the
span and you might also think there's
something funny that this equation and
that equation are exactly the same so
how come one of them is meant to know
it's picking out the beginning and the
other the end and again you know we're
not doing anything to impose that we're
just saying new network it is your job
to learn you have to learn a matrix here
and a different one over there so that
one of them will pick out parts of the
representation that indicates starts of
ANSYS fans and the other one ends of it
answers bands and so that will then
again pressure the neural network to
sort of self organize itself in such a
way that there will be some parts of
this hidden representation that will be
good at learning starts of spans you
know maybe they'll be carried backwards
by the backwards lsdm and some parts of
it will be good at learning where spans
end and then the W matrix will be able
to pick out those parts of the
representation but yeah that's a system
yeah so so this is the basic Stanford
attentive reader model and it's just no
more complex than that and the
interesting thing is you know that very
simple model actually works nicely well
so this is going back in time again this
is the February 2017 squad version one
leader board but at that time that
provides like your voice and neural
networks quite a bit of your success is
training your hype of parameters and
optimizing your model really well and
sometimes you know it's been repeatedly
proven in neural network land
that often you can get much better
scores than you would think from very
simple models if you optimize them
really well so there have been multiple
cycles in sort of deep learning research
where there was a paper that did
something and then the next person says
here's more more more complex model that
works better and then someone else
published a paper saying here's an even
more complex than that model that works
better and then someone points out no if
you go back to the first model and just
really train its hyper parameter as well
you can beat both of those two models
and that was effectively the case that
was what was happening with this stand
for the attentive reason that you know
Beca
back in February 2017 if you just train
this model really well it could actually
outperform most of the early squad
systems I mean in particular it could
outperform the by death and the version
of by def that was around in early 2017
and you know various of these arbor
systems from other people that it was
actually at that time it was pretty
close to the best system that anyone had
built as I've already pointed out to you
the numbers have gone up a lot since
then so I'm not int claiming that this
system is still as good as the best
systems that you can build for there you
go so that's a simple system that
already works pretty well but of course
you want his system to work better and
so Dan she did quite a bit of work on
that and so here I'll just mention a few
things for Stanford attentive reader
plus plus as to what kind of things can
you do to make the model better and so
here's the sort of a picture of the sort
of improved system and we'll go through
some of the differences and what makes
it better there's something I didn't
have before that I should just mention
right sort of this whole mod all the
parameters of this model were just
trained in to end where your training
objective is simply working out how
accurately you're predicting the start
position and how accurately your predict
the in position so that the attention
gives you a probability distribution
over start positions and end positions
so you're just being asked what
probability estimate are you giving to
the true start position and the true end
position and to the extent that though
you know those aren't one you've then
got loss that is then being sort of
summed in terms of log probability okay
so how is this model more complex now
than what I showed before essentially in
two main ways so the first one is
looking at the question we still run the
by lsdm as before but now what we're
going to do is it's a little bit crew
just to take the in states of the LST
and concatenate them together it turns
out that you can do better by making use
of all states from an LS TM and this is
true for most tasks where you want some
kind of sentence representation from a
sequence model it turns out you can
generally gain by using all of that
rather than just the endpoints of it so
but this is just an interesting general
thing to know again because you know
this is actually a another variant of
how that how you can use attention there
you know a lot of so the last two years
of neural NLP can be summed up as people
have found a lot of clever ways to use
attention and that's been powering just
about all the advances so what we want
to do is we want to have attention over
the positions in this LS TM but you know
this is we're processing the query first
so it sort of seems like we've got
nothing to calculate attention with
respect to so what we do is we just
invent something so we just sort of
invent here is a vector and it's
sometimes called a sentinel or some word
like that but you know we just in our PI
thoughts say here is a vector we're
going to calculate we initialize it
randomly and we're going to calculate
attention with respect to that
vector and we're going to use those
attention scores to work out where to
pay attention in this bio STM and then
we just sort of trained that vector so
it gets values and so then we end up
with a weighted sum of the time steps of
that LS TM that are then form a question
representation second change the
pictures I only show a shallow by lsdm
but you know it turns out you can do
better if you have a deep bio STM and so
you use a three layer deep bio STM
rather than single layer okay then the
other change is in the passage
representations and this part arguably
gets a little bit more heavy but they're
things that you can do that make the
numbers go up I guess okay so so firstly
for the representation of words rather
than only using the glove representation
that the input vectors are expanded so
that so a named entity recognized in a
part of speech tagger as run and since
those are sort of small sets of values
that the output of those is just one hot
encoded and concatenated on to the word
vector so it represents if it's a
location or a person name and whether
it's a noun or a verb word frequency
proves to be a bit useful so there's a
your concatenated on sort of a
representation of the word frequency as
just sort of a float of the unigram
probability and then this part is kind
of key to getting some further advancers
which is well turns out that we can do a
better job by doing some sort of better
understanding of the matching between
the question and the passage and this
feature seems like it's very simple but
turns out to actually give you quite a
lot of value so you're simply saying
for each word and the question so for
the each word and I said that wrong for
each word in the passage
you're just saying does this word appear
in the question and if so you're setting
a 1-bit into the input and that's done
in three different ways
exact match uncased match and Lema match
so that means something like drive and
driving will match and just that sort of
indicator of here's where in the passage
that's in the question in theory those
systems should be able to work that out
anyway but explicitly indicate it gives
quite a bit of value and then this last
one does a sort of a softer version of
that where it's using word embedding
similarities to sort of calculate a kind
of similarity between questions and
answers and that's a slightly complex
equation that you can look up but
effectively that you're getting the
embedding of words and the question
answers each of those you're running
through a single hidden layer neural
network your dot product in it and then
putting all that through a softmax and
that kind of gives you a sort of word
similarity score and that helps as well
okay so here's the kind of just overall
picture this gives you so if you
remember there was the sort of the
classical NLP with logistic regression
baseline there's around 51 so the sort
of a fairly simple model like the
Stanford attentive reader gives you an
enormous boost in performance right
that's giving you close to 30 percent
performance gain and then you know from
there people have kept on pushing up
neural systems but you know so this
gives you kind of in some sense
three-quarters of the value over the
traditional and/or P system and then the
much more complex neural systems that
come after it yeah in terms of error
reductions they're huge but it's sort of
more like they're giving you the sort of
12% after that why do these system
work such a ton better than traditional
systems and so actually did some error
analysis of this and you know it turns
out that most of their gains is because
they can just do better semantic
matching of words similarities of leaf
phrasings that are semantically related
but don't use the same words so you know
to the extent that the question is you
know where was Christopher Manning born
and the sentence says Christopher
Manning was born in Australia you know a
traditional NLP system would get that
right - but to the extent that you being
able to get it right
depends on being able to match sort of
looser semantic matches to that tree
understand that sort of you know the
place of birth has to be matching was
born or something that's where the
neural systems actually do work much
much better okay so that's not the end
of the story on question answering
systems and I wanted to say just a
little bit about more complex systems to
give you some idea of what goes on after
that but before I go further into that
are there any questions on up until now
Stanford attentive reader
yeah that question about attention in
general every example we've seen has
just been a linear mapping with a waste
matrix as anybody tried to convert that
to a deep neural network and see what
happens so yes they have well at least a
shallow neural network I'll actually
show an example then just a minute so
maybe I will save it to then but yeah
absolutely
yeah people have done that and that's
can be a good thing to play with
anything else okay okay so um so this is
a picture of the by def system so this
is the one from AI to u-dub and the by
def system is very well known it's
another sort of classic version of
question-answering system that lots of
people have used and built off and you
know some of it isn't completely
different what we saw before but it has
various addition so there are word
embeddings just like we had before
there's a bias TM running just like what
we had before
and that's being done for both the
passage and the question but there are
some different things that are happening
as well so one of them is rather than
just having word embeddings it also
processes the questions and passages at
the character level and that's something
that we're going to talk about coming up
ahead in the class there's been a lot of
work at doing character level processing
and recent neural NLP but I don't want
to talk about that now the main
technical innovation of the by def model
is this attention flow layer because
that's in its name bi-directional
attention flow and so there was a model
of attention flow where you have
attention flowing in both directions
between the query and the passage and
that was their main innovation and it
was quite useful in their model
but beyond that there's you know there's
some more stuff to this model so after
the attention flow layer there's again
multiple layers of bi-directional l
STM's running and then on top of that
their output layer is more complex than
the sort of simple attention version
that I showed previously so let's just
look at that in a bit more detail so for
the attention flow layer so their
motivation here was in the Stanford
attentive reader we used attention to
map from the representation of the
question on to the words of the passage
but you know so as question as a whole
mapping onto the words of the passage
where their idea was well presumably you
could do better by mapping in both
directions at the word level so you
should be sort of finding passage words
that you and map onto question words and
question words that you can map onto
passage words and if you do that in both
directions with attention flowing and
then run off another round of sequence
models on top of that that you'll just
be able to do much better matching
between the two of them and so the way
they do that is that they they've got
the button so at the bottom layers
they've sort of run these two LS TM so
they have representations in their OS DM
for each word and word and passage
position and at this point I have to put
in a slight apology because I just stole
the equations and so the letters that I
use change sorry but so these are the
the question individual words and these
are the passage individual words and so
what they're then wanting to do is to
say for each passage weren't each
question word I want to work out a
similarity score and the way they work
out that similarity score is they build
a big
concatenated vector so there's the Alice
TM representation of the passage word
the question word and then they throw in
a third thing where they do a huh damad
products on element-wise product of the
question word and the context word you
know for a new net purist throwing in
these kind of Hadamard products is a
little bit of a cheat because you kind
of would hope that a neural net might
just learn that this relation between
the passage and the question was useful
to look at but you can find a lot of
models that put in this kind of Hadamard
product because it's sort of a very easy
way of sort of having a model that knows
that matching is a good idea
because essentially this is sort of
looking for each question and passage
word pair you know do the vectors look
similar in various dimensions you can
sort of access very well from looking at
that have a mild product so that so you
take that big vector and you then dot
product it with learned weight matrix
and that gives you a similarity score
between each position in the question
and the context and so then what you're
going to do is use that to define
attentions that go in both directions so
forth the context a question attention
this one's completely straightforward so
you put these similarity scores through
a softmax so for each of the eye
positions in the passage you're sort of
having a softmax which is giving you a
probability distribution over question
words and then you're coming up with a
new representation of the ice position
which is then the attention weighted
version the attention weighted average
of those question words so you're sort
of having the attention weighted view of
the question mapped onto each position
in the passage you then want to do
something in the reverse direction but
the one in the reverse
correction is done subtly differently so
you're again starting off with the these
same similarity scores but this time
they're sort of wanting to sort of
really assign which position in which
position and the question is the one
that's sort of aligning the most so that
they're finding a max and so that
they're finding which is the most
aligned one and so then for each of for
each of the eyes they're finding the
most aligned question word and so then
they're doing a soft max over these M
scores and then those are being used to
form a new representation of the passage
by sort of summing over these attention
weights okay so you build these things
up and this system gives you a new
representation where you have your
original representations of the passage
words you have a new representations
that you've built from this
bi-directional attention flow and you
look at these sort of Hadamard products
of them and that then gives you kind of
the output of the by def layer and that
output of the by def layer is then what
sort of being fed as the input into
these next sequence of lsdm layers okay
and so yeah so then that's the modeling
layer you have another two BIOS TM
layers and so the way they do the answer
spann selection is a bit more complex as
well so that they're then sort of taking
the output of the modeling layer and
putting it through a sort of a dense
feed-forward neural network layer and
then soft maxing over that and that's
then getting a distribution of a start
and then you're running yet another lsdm
King a distribution finish yeah so that
gives you some idea of a more complex
model
you know in some sense the summary if
you go further forward than here is that
sort of most of the work in the last
couple of years people have been
producing progressively more complex
architectures with lots of variants of
attention and effectively that has been
giving good gains I think I'll skip
since time is running over out showing
you that one but let me just mention
this fusion net model which was done by
people at Microsoft because this relates
the answer to the attention question
right so so people have definitely used
different versions of attention right so
then some of the stuff that we've shown
we've tend to emphasize this by linear
attention where you've got two vectors
mediated by a matrix and I guess
traditionally at Stanford NLP we've
liked this version of attention since it
seems to vary directly learn a
similarity but other people have used a
little neural net so this is sort of a
shallow neural net to work out attention
scores and there's sort of no reason why
you couldn't say maybe it'd be even
better if I make that a deep neural net
and add another layer and some of them
you know to be perfectly honest some of
the results that have been done by
people including at Google argue that
actually that MLP version of attention
is better so there's something to
explore in that direction but actually
the people in fusion net didn't head
that direction because they said look we
want to use tons and tons of attention
so we want an attention computation
that's pretty efficient and so it's bad
news if you have to be evaluating a
little dense neural net at every
position every time that you do
attention so this by linear form is
fairly appealing but they then did some
playing with it so rather than having a
W matrix you can reduce the rank and
complexity of your W matrix by dividing
it into the product of two lower rank
matrices so you can have a U and V
matrix and if you make these rectangular
matrices that are kind of skinny you
can then have a server lower rank
factorization and that seems a good idea
and then they thought well maybe really
you want your attention distribution to
be symmetric so we can actually put in
the middle here we can have the U and
the B so to speak be the same and just
have a diagonal matrix in the middle and
that might be useful way to think of it
and that all makes sense from linear
algebra terms but then they thought off
nonlinearities are really good in deep
learning so why don't we sort of stick
the left and right half through a reloj
and maybe that will help
which doesn't so much make sense in
linear algebra terms but that's actually
what they ended up using as their
attention form so lots of things you can
play with when doing your final project
yeah and but you know their argument is
still you know that doing attention this
way is actually much much cheaper and so
they can use a lot of attention and so
they build this very complex tons of
attention model which I'm not going to
try and explain all of now but I will
show you this picture and so a point
that they make is that a lot of the
different models that people have
explored in different years you know do
you know they're sort of doing different
kinds of attention that you could be
doing attention right lining up with the
original LS TM you could run both sides
through some stuff and do attention you
can do self attention inside your layer
that there are a lot of different
attentions the different models have
explored and essentially what they're
wanting to say is let's do all of those
and let's make it deep and do it all
five times and the numbers will go up
and to some extent the answer is yeah
they do and the model ends up scoring
very well okay so the one last thing I
just wanted to mention but not explained
is I mean in the last year there's then
been a further revolution and how well
people can do these tasks and so people
have developed algorithms which
produce contextual word representation
so that means that rather than a
traditional word vector you have a
representation of each word in a
particular context so here's the word
frog in this particular context and the
way people build those representations
is using something like a language
modeling task like a bee talked about of
saying putting probabilities of words in
context to learn a context specific word
representation and Elmo was the first
well-known such model and then people
from Google came up with bert which
worked even better and so bird is really
in some sense a super complex attention
architecture doing a language modeling
like objective we're going to talk about
these later and not going to talk about
them now but if you look at the current
squad 2.0 liter board you will quickly
sorry yes oh I put the wrong slide and
that was the bottom of the leaderboards
slipped at the last minute if you go
back to my slide which had the top of
the leaderboard you will have noticed at
the top of the leaderboard every single
one of the top systems users bird so
that's something that you may want to
consider that you may want to consider
how you could use it as a sub module
that you can add other stuff to as many
of these systems do ok done for today